dans cet atelier quand l'occasion se
présente il vaut mieux filer à toute
allure pour avoir le privilège de le
découvrir
le dragster j existe certes urnes
voilà quand même mais bon
cinq en cinq ans pour la concevoir la
[Musique]
jante en carbone coque en aluminium
sélecteur de vitesses pneumatique moteur
gsxr sans vous non plus n'y comprenais
pas grand-chose retenait que ce beau
bébé de moins de 200 kg comptabilise 500
chevaux
aucun autre engin ne fait le poids le
dragster pulvérise les records
si aux antilles venir martinique ni on
voit d'où ils ont déjà conçu une moto
localement je veux dire avec ces
puissances à à saint martin les
véhicules qu'ils ont comme en guadeloupe
c'est les motos qui sont importés mais
faire une puissance sortir localement
c'est la première fois que cet effet et
c'est ce que cette moto avec des pièces
venues des états unis
il a construit de ses propres mains une
moto programmé pour monter une vitesse
de 300 km heure après une série de tests
de puissance à la mise à feu
son bruit se passe de commentaires
ce qui me manque c'est un circuit pour
pouvoir essayer la moto parce que le
problème pour moi
elle a été conçue seat avec 500 chevaux
les saisons se vaut je les ai à la
hausse mais pour le moment j'ai pas de
lieu où je peux essayer pour voir
comment les gens la moto à se comporter
je vous le départ comment il va se
comporter en pleine accélération
et aussi comment va se comporter au
freinage sans avoir testé sa machine
il se rendra en guadeloupe le 6 mai pour
le 400 m départ arrêté à goyave une
première étape pour ce passionné de
sensations fortes car il vise les états
unis et combien vous laissons en
tracteur en novembre prochain pour la
finale sgtm de la floride